The Joe Rogan Experience and one of the
things that I want to talk to because I
haven't talked to you since the pandemic
start last time I talked to you was
screwball right
like how long ago was that oh yeah what
2019 yeah right before the [ __ ] hit the
fan that was the last time we talked
when we were talking about that
documentary and then when all this
happened and so much of the wackiness
and the you know the controversies
coming out of Florida like you embrace
the chaos of Florida yeah Florida
[ __ ] is our genre and it's our also
our top export I think is as well it's
really what we provide the rest of but
for you you I mean look about how much
your work is about Florida the cooking
Cowboys series you know all the stuff on
A-Rod like all the there's there's so
much of your your work
the petrifying I'm a Florida native you
know in a lifelong Miami and I think the
petrifying thing that I've learned
through the years and it's not my theory
uh TD almond called Miami the city of
the future and effectively the Florida
of today is the America of tomorrow and
more importantly the Miami of today more
specifically the Miami of today is the
America of tomorrow so if you want to
know
what uh challenges will face or
calamities will befall us as a nation in
the Years or even decades to come you
need to only look at the canary in the
coal mine which is which is South
Florida do you think that's because of
it's very vulnerable to climate change
first of all right like there's there's
estimates about how long Miami can last
yeah but not good yeah they don't they
think you got about two decades right
isn't that the the current thought I'm a
renter let me put you that way
I've lived there my whole life I don't
own any property in Miami it's probably
a good move I'm not bullish it does it
seems like it's gonna go underwater
right yeah it'll definitely be
underwater it's just a question of when
it's all like there like the the ground
itself is very porous is that correct
yeah I mean you know we had uh uh
reclaimed Wetlands that's Miami Beach
that's where Champlain Towers is
reclaimed Wetlands what does that mean
it was [ __ ] mangroves swamps yeah
swamp and that we reclaimed which means
we filled it in and there's still porous
Limestone underneath that Champlain
Towers only had water coming at it from
the front the back above and below but
other than that it was totally dry this
is the tower that collapsed yeah I mean
just battered we're getting battered
they were on that porous Limestone yeah
that was oh yeah yeah built on reclaimed
wetlands and so I'll tell you right now
as we speak this is the
um the king Tides you know what the king
tides are no they happen every September
October and November not the entire time
but there's like a week here a week in
there for those three months it is what
we call Sunny Day flooding so it has to
do with the tides it has to do with the
the distance between the Sun and the
Moon and the Earth and it floods in the
sunlight
it we can get as much as 12 inches 12
inches above the highest high tide of
the year so it's just it's not from rain
it's not now here's the problem we're
still in Hurricane Season which means
rain exacerbates it inclement weather
can we're totally [ __ ] when it rains
on top of the king tires but this is
just like a day like you just if you
were in a low-lying area or Waterfront
or Ocean Front bay front that's just
what sunny day it's perfectly it could
be perfectly beautiful and you could
have as much as 12 inches above the
highest high tide so it's just an
unusual level of the ocean yeah just a
quirk of of the tides it happens every
year uh off and on for three months
yeah that's in in the dis we call it
sunny day flooding that's the thing that
we have there I mean you know Miami We
Make It Rain but we now we have sunny
sunny day flooding is a thing and
there's nothing they can do like New
Orleans like put up some sort of a
some sort of a wall damn so the the Army
Corps of Engineers proposed a kind of
futuristic post-apocalyptic you know
after the flood well pre-flood kind of a
wall and Miami said no gracias no thank
you we don't want that we'll we'll we'll
fend for ourselves did they say no
because it was too expensive or did they
say no because no the Army Corps of
Engineers I think was good I think it
was gonna be federally funded they just
didn't want this unsightly unseemly kind
of a wall in our beautiful town and but
what they did want is they wanted a
signature Bridge we're building like
this 800 million dollar bridge that we
don't need that's but it's it's super
it's super pretty as we say in Miami
it's super pretty and somebody probably
got a good deal oh yeah oh you better
believe the contractors that's the thing
that's why the Miami of today is the
America of tomorrow it's really the
corruption dysfunction and non-stop
construction that's really what it is
it's this Anything Goes Wild West kind
of mentality because you know I I said
this before on the show you know La is
where you go and you want to be somebody
New York is where you go when you are
somebody and Miami is where you go and
you want to be somebody else it's always
been a sunny place for shady people the
Florida man phenomenon it's just like
you know we just if you have it's not
New England it's not what's your name
who's your daddy everyone's Nouveau
riche in Miami so no one cares where
your money came from as long as the
booze is flowing and everybody's dancing
the music's going nobody gives a [ __ ]
and it's always been that place it's
always been that party place you were
you were telling me before about how
during uh it was it was it the 70s the
80s these recording artists would go
down to Miami yeah like listen uh Miami
is just it's America's Casablanca you
know and so some of the biggest records
of all time
um I mean back when that was a business
like you could sell tens of millions of
albums uh everybody went to Miami Eric
Clapton was one of the first Jimmy
Buffett the Bee Gees the Eagles Crosby
Stills Nash and Young on the Allman
Brothers Fleetwood Mac and they were
doing
all those records that we all still know
today from the 70s they recorded a mixed
or mastered at least in part
um uh uh uh Glenn Frey and Don Henley
wrote the lyrics to Hotel California in
a rented mansion on Miami Beach where it
had that had been the love nest
um of Howard Hughes and Eva Gardner uh
uh Winston Churchill used it as a winter
home uh and um the Watergate burglars
and Howard hunt used it as well and then
um Steven Stills used it he was hanging
out there with like Shel Silverstein
they were it was like a weird scene and
then uh eventually the Eagles came down
to do Hotel California and wrote the
lyrics they locked themselves these two
guys in a [ __ ] room and they they
just the housekeeper left sandwiches and
and drinks at the door because the door
was closed and they came down in
bathrobes one day with with legal pads
yeah legal pads and said we have it we
have we have we have the lyrics and so
everybody everybody and it was a
communal scene too it's kind of like
your place with the you know everybody
just sort of like stops by and get
tested people stop by and again it was
like that because you had all these
artists in every route like so there was
pick up basketball games outside you'd
drive up and there'd be the Bee Gees
playing The Allman Brothers playing Eric
Clapton in a pickup basketball game and
they to this day criteria Studios they
have a wooden upright piano and the
rumor has it one day there was an artist
I won't mention the name was playing and
had a baggie of cocaine on the top of
the piano and he was playing and the
baggie fell open fell boom puff of smoke
on the keys of the piano appropriately
and you grab the bag and Salvage what he
could and then for the next several
months the people at the studio who were
to that would stick a straw between the
keys on the on the piano and try to
mostly dust they were probably snorting
but like we're just trying to salvage
whatever they could from there so the
the the joke was that um they had a a
line item on the uh the bills because
that's the thing they were away from the
watchful eyes and ears of the labels
which were all based in New York and la
so they would go to Miami and no one
knew what the [ __ ] was going I didn't
have publicists or producers from or
Executives rather from from the
recording studio so they would send them
bills to pay for the studio time there'd
be a line item for cocaine but you
couldn't say
cocaine
um and I think by the way cocaine was at
that time was probably part of the
appeal of bringing the artist to Miami
to be fair probably right but it was
under the the category of piano tuning
was was the cookie so you get uh like
some you know someone you know accounts
and a record label call up and say hey I
have a question about this this invoice
um it's it's there's five thousand
dollars here for piano tuning but
there's only one ballad on the album so
this with all this [ __ ] piano tuning
there's there was an act oh God I'm not
gonna say it but there was a band
who came down in the 80s to record a
criteria
and then they came down again in the 90s
and the guy who runs the studio Trevor
his mom was the manager before him so he
was a little kid running around this
scene if you can imagine a little kid in
Miami in the 70s running around this
scene this is an incredible Place Aretha
Franklin did the respect record at
criteria James Brown did I feel good
recorded that song at criteria it's a
really historic place and so he this
band comes in and he says the lead
singer he says Hey listen I don't know
if you remember you were down here 15
years ago whatever back in the late 70s
early 80s doing this this record and the
singer says
I have no memory of that whatsoever
except for one thing
he said one night apparently
we were done recording here and someone
took us into the neighborhood it's like
in a residential kind of area into the
neighborhood to This Woman's house and
she brought out a brick of cocaine an
entire kilo of cocaine heat so I'd never
seen that before she put it down on the
coffee table we're sitting on the couch
she put it down like this is a big band
uh they put it she put it down on the
coffee table she cut it open
and all I remember from my entire
experience in Miami is the smell of that
entire kilo of cocaine like just what it
feels like when an entire like an entire
kilo of cocaine is opened up before you
and it hits and it hits you have you
ever done Coke never me neither never
but hearing that
I want to sniff
I just want to know take away for that I
want to know what that's like watch the
entire episode for free only on Spotify